es ist halloween und sie will nur eine
unbeschwerte party feiern doch für eine
14 jährige aus ulm wird der 31 oktober
2009 10 zu einem albtraum
sie wird vergewaltigt dafür laut anklage
verantwortlich fünf männer die seit
heute vor gericht stehen ein 14-jähriges
mädchen betäubt und mehrfach
vergewaltigt
ein vorwurf dem sich ab heute fünf
männer im alter von 15 bis 27 jahren vor
dem gericht in ulm stellen müssen
jeder der fünf angeklagten ist
asylbewerber stammt aus afghanistan dem
iran oder irak zur tatzeit dem 31
oktober 2009 10 war jeder der
beschuldigten in einer
flüchtlingsunterkunft einem ehemaligen
bauernhof im baden-württembergischen
illerkirchberg untergebracht
ihr opfer eine 14 jährige schülerin
feiert in der ulmer innenstadt halloween
sie ist alkoholisiert als sie auf die
männer trifft lässt sich dazu über
wiesen die angeklagten in die
flüchtlingsunterkunft zu begleiten
ihr wird ein betäubungsmittel
verabreicht als das mädchen wehrlos auf
dem sofa einschläft vergehen sich die
männer mehr als neun mal an ihr
vergewaltigen sie abwechselnd
und hagen stegmüller hat für uns den
ersten prozesstag beobachte tagen
geliefert ab die der erste prozesstag
vor ist ja dieser erste prozesstag war
auch verstörend die details die
staatsanwalt bischofsberger vorgelesen
hat
haben das publikum entsetzt gerade was
die drogen betrifft
man hat ja dem dem kind zunächst
marihuana amphetamin eingeflößt
später als es dann von der von seiner
benommenheit wieder aufgewacht ist gab
es eine tablette mit ecstasy so dass es
sofort wieder berauscht war dann hat man
sich mit an ihr vergangen und
anschließend insgesamt hat einer allein
ein 16 jähriger iraker hat sich allein
fünf mal an ihr vergangen
also furchtbare erlebnisse wird dieses
mädchen anstieg müller für danke für die
ersten informationen vom prozessauftakt
und du wirst ihn weiter für uns
beobachten